for wise you've got a number of days to
reflect on the turmoil what will turkey
do now with its southern border how will
the dialogue change between Syria Isis
the Islamic state and Turkey well Tom as
you know in the past few weeks Turkey
has been trying to build bridges to both
local players regional players and
international players reconciliations
with Israel reconciliations with Russia
statements about a new chapter and
relations between Turkey and Egypt the
prime minister after he even dare to say
that you would like to normalize
relations with Syria and Iraq which is
quite a I mean very radical shift my
take on it tom is that turkey that's not
just need I mean to normalize relations
with its neighbors and the world it
needs to make peace at home this is the
most important challenge facing turkey
today my fear is that President order on
is going to use this particular moment
as he has said it's a gift from God to
do what you know to purge the military
to cleanse the military a crack crack
down against the judiciary and and
political rivals I mean I don't
understand why would you basically
dismiss 3000 judges and prosecutors I
this is tells you a great deal that
president otto hahn is going to use this
particular moment to really cleanse the
political system of any rivals both I
mean in the military and also you know
in the political landscape broadly
speaking dr. Georges when I look at the
new Turkey and the new military that mr.
Diwan will have they need to deal with
the ancient question of the Kurds how
will President Erdogan with the fifty
percent support he has with the Islamist
support how will you how will he
regenerate the Kurdish relationship I
mean I think this is what i meant
president otto von the challenge facing
president oda want is to make peace at
home is to basically
begin the process of reconciliation not
only with his political rivals in Turkey
but also with the Kurds what you have
now Tom as you know in the past year is
the kind of a mini civil war between the
Turkish state and the Kurds in
particular a small segment the PKK which
is a very radical and militant segment
but sadly speaking I don't think I don't
expect any major shift in the way
President Erdogan has dealt with the
Kurds because remember this has to do
with the white of nationalism he's using
I mean the fight against the PKK in
order to really strengthen his position
at home and that's why it is that the
next few days and next few months will
tell us a great deal whether president
otto hahn would rise up to the challenge
in particular vis-a-vis the kurds and
his political rivals at home the
direction travel is not that way though
the direction of travel is less
democracy not more of treating the Kurds
more harshly than ferrer I why should
these people believe that he's going to
step up isn't the direction to travel
more likely do we get more of this mini
Civil War as you describe it because
that's been the situation over the last
year that's what I fear and in fact the
early signs are not reassuring at all
when you basically dismiss 3,000 judges
and prosecutors attacking I don't
believe for a moment that three judges
and prosecutors were part of the coup I
just don't believe it and obviously what
he is trying to do as he has said very
much he said this is a virus within the
state he is trying to cleanse the
political system he's using this
particular opportunity as a gift from
God quote unquote in order to basically
crown himself as the unrivaled isn't
anybody else outside the country will
will diplomatic overtures that he should
not go down this route be in any way
acted upon well look I mean the entire
world whether it's President Obama or
the French or the British as saying look
respect rules off your part of Europe if
you want to join the European Union must
basically respect the rule of law
president otto and that's what he does
he does not take any hostages right and
my take on it the tragedy president
order on and Turkish politics is that
the opposition is very weak that is his
party AK is the dominant partner and
when you have a week of position
basically you can do whatever you can
nacoo itself in fact provides president
or the one with the immunity the
ideological ammunition to dominate the
political landscape for the next ten
years or so who was hurt awan sat at the
istanbul airport in front of the
portrait of Ataturk Ataturk 1923
revolution he died and i believe 1938
did kamal ism died friday night cam
ilysm has been dying for the past 20 or
30 years keep in mind that the rise of
auto and represent a generational shift
in Turkish politics he came in power in
2003 the reason why the coup failed not
because of the ineptitude of this small
segment within the military Otto Hahn
tom has been able to create a broadly
based social base of support millions of
Turks have benefited from the economic
revolution in Turkey remember Turkey has
the largest 70s economy in the world
millions of people have become part of
the middle class and that's why this
particular coof has failed met because
the military generals and junior
officers did not rly pre-plan and they
did not but because now turkey has
shifted turkey is not no longer about
Kemal Ataturk it's about really order on
here is the new face of the new turkey